صحيح ان الارقام متضاربه ولا احصائيات
دقيقه لهذا الملف لكن الثابت ان عشرات
الالاف لا زالوا مفقودين اذا هذه خريطه
المفقودين في الموصل اختفى اكثر من ثمانيه
الاف شخص منذ عام
2014 في محافظه صلاح الدين هناك اكثر من
15 الف مغيبا في ايضا في الانبار هناك
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف شخص مختفا وفي دياله
اكثر من 2000 غياب لكن السؤال اين هم
في البلاد اي يوجد نحو 20 سجنا باعترافي
وزاره العدل العراقيه تساؤل اخر ان كانت
هذه السجون تابعه للدوله فلماذا لا يمكن
العثور على المفقودين الاتهامات تلاحق
المليشيات نظرا لتورطها في عمليات الخطف
والاخفاء لان هذه الفصائل لديها ايضا
سجونها الخاصه وهنا كما تظهر امامكم منطقه
الزعفرانيه بالقرب المدخل الجنوبي للعاصمه
بغداد فهنا يقع سجن شبل الزيدي قائد كتائب
الامام علي والمطور في قضايا عديده ومن
بينها الخطف والقتل ننتقل الان الى شمال
شرق العاصمه بغداد حيث تقع منطقه صدر
القناه حنا يوجد السجن الحشد حيث كان مقرا
للشرطه الاتحاديه سابقا واليوم هو تابع
للمليشيات المسلحه وفي موقع اخر وتحديدا
في منطقه الجاذريه رصافه بغداد توجد دائره
امن ميليشيا
تضم ايضا مراكز توقيف وهذه الدائره تضم
ايضا مقرات ومقار للحرس الثوري الايراني
الى مثلث برمودا العراقي قلعه الميليشيات
والحرس الثوري في الصخر المنطقه المحرمه
على الدوله تنتشروا السجون سريه تابعه
لهذه القوه